when you walk around the place where you
live most of the times you feel pretty
safe and comfortable right now
imagine if there were landlines buried
right here scatter around you never know
when you might step on one that's how it
is for many in my home country Columbia
as a result of a 50-year internal armed
conflict we have an undetermined number
of Landman buried throughout the
countryside affecting more than 1/3 of
the Colombian population these and take
personnel mines are designed to maim not
to kill their targets the logic behind
this which is awful
is that more resources are taking up
caring for an injured soldier than
dealing with a person who has been
killed I met Adriana Rodriguez about
five years ago while I was working for
the Colombian government as a
documentary filmmaker during the
conflict she was forced to leave her
house with her kids in her arms one day
one of her neighbors was killed while he
stepped on a landmine he was actually
inside an abandoned house not outside a
house exactly like the one adrionna was
forced to live ever since she has been
living with the fear that she or her
children my 7 landmine you know the
common conflict is being running for so
long that neither me nor my mom have
seen our country in peace and for
someone like me who has been living
detached from all this suffering there
was only two options either I get used
to it or I can't read I can try to
change it with all my heart and I have
to admit that for almost 30 years I was
getting used to it you know but
something changed for me when
made my wife she is a political
scientist completely passionate about
the Colombian armed conflict she helped
me to understand how deeply our country
has been affected by landmines and by
war we decided to come here to the
United States
in search of new skills that enable us
to contribute in a better way to our
society and maybe even help heal it
while in grad school I saw developing an
augmented reality relief broth
application to help military personnel
to deactivate landlines more safely
during that time I also realize that
Colombia is not the only country in the
world that have to worry about landlines
in fact more than 58 countries are still
contaminated with any sort of explosive
device only in 2015 due to an escalation
of war in countries like Libya Syria
Ukraine and Yemen the number of
landmines almost double from three
thousand six hundred and ninety five to
six thousand four hundred and sixty-one
people imagine that while some countries
are trying to get rid of landmines some
others are increasing their use but what
happened when a conflict that involved
landmines comes to an end there are two
consequences on the one hand the
internally displaced population will
start returning to their lands and on
the other hand hidden landmines are
gonna start exploding more often on the
civilian side that's the reason why I
decided to join the computer science
department at NYU along with Professor
Doug DeSilva to start develop an app
called mine safe mine safe uses
information from the community to
suggest paths that have been declared as
the most transited without accident or
incident caused by a landmine these
traffic patterns can also be used to
determine the top priority stones to be
demanded
almost 15 million people are living now
in the countryside of Colombia imagine
for a moment if we can crowdsource
information from all of them to help
people like Adriana and her children to
find safe and reliable paths this
information can not only be used for
that this information can also help them
to become more productive farmers will
be able to find which lands has been
cleared from explosive devices and in
that way they will be able to find new
fertile grounds to start growing food
again mine safe has now a partnership
with the Colombian government for the
initial pilot and we have now some
connections with Cambodia and Somalia as
well this project is being funded by
private money here in the United States
but we don't want to stop here will not
go big and we want to scale the project
to every single place where landmines
are still a threat the Colombian armed
conflict is finally coming to an end but
the consequences of years of war are
still buried under our feet we at mine
safe are working to her both people and
land to find peace
[Applause]